dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr. Carol Jean IFA here
today it is almost taken for granted
that neural network based learning
algorithms are capable of identifying
objects in images or even rightful
coherent sentences about them but fewer
people know that there is also parallel
research on trying to break these
systems for instance some of these image
detectors can be fooled by adding a
little noise to the image and in some
specialized cases we can even perform
something that is called the one pixel
attack let's have a look at some
examples changing just this one pixel
can make a classifier think that this
ship is a car or that this horse is a
frog and amusingly be quite confident
about its guess note that the choice of
this pixel and the color is by no means
random and it needs solving a
mathematical optimization problem to
find out exactly how to perform this
trying to build better image detectors
while other researchers are trying to
break them is not the only arms race we
are experiencing in machine learning
research for instance a few years ago
deepmind introduced an incredible
learning algorithm that looked at the
screen much like a human would but was
able to reach superhuman levels in
playing a few Atari games it was a
spectacular milestone in AI research
they also just have published a
follow-up paper on this that will cover
very soon so make sure to subscribe and
hit the bell icon to not miss it when it
appears in the near future
interestingly while these learning
algorithms are being improved at a
staggering pace there is a parallel
subfield where researchers endeavor to
break these learning systems by slightly
changing the information they are
presented with let's have a look at open
e eyes example their first method adds a
tiny bit of noise to a large portion of
the video input where the difference is
barely perceptible but it forces the
learning algorithm to choose a different
action then it would have chosen
otherwise
in the other one the different
modification was used that has the
smaller footprint but is more visible
for instance in Punk adding a tiny fake
ball to the game can coerce the learner
into going down when it was originally
planning to go up it is important to
emphasize that the researchers did not
do this by hand the algorithm itself is
able to pick up game specific knowledge
by itself and find out how to fool the
other AI using it both attacks perform
remarkably well however it is not always
true that we can just change these
images or the playing environment to our
desire to fool these algorithms so with
this an even more interesting question
arises is it possible to just enter the
game as a player and perform interesting
stunts that can reliably win against
these AIS and with this we have arrived
to the subject of today's paper this is
the you shall not pass game where the
red agent is trying to hold back the
blue character and not let it cross the
line here you see two regular AIS duking
it out sometimes the red wins sometimes
the blue is able to get through nothing
too crazy here this is the reference
case which is somewhat well-balanced and
now hold on to your papers because this
adversarial agent that this new paper
proposes does this
you may think this was some kind of
glitch and I put the incorrect footage
here by accident no this is not an error
you can believe your eyes
it basically collapses and does
absolutely nothing
this can't be a useful strategy can it
well look at that it still wins the
majority of the time this is very
confusing how can that be
let's have a closer look this red agent
is normally a somewhat competent player
as you can see here it can punch the
blue victim and make it fall we now
replaced this red player with the
adversarial agent which collapsed and it
almost feels like it hypnotized the blue
agent to also fall and now squeeze your
papers because the normal red opponents
win rate was 47% and this collapsing
chap wins 86% of the time it not only
wins but it wins much much more reliably
than a competent AI what is this
wizardry the answer is that the
adversary induces of distribution
activations to understand what that
exactly means let's have a look at this
chart this tells us how likely it is
that the actions of the AI against
different opponents are normal as you
see when this agent named Xue plays
against itself the bars are in the
positive region meaning that normal
things are happening things go as
expected however that's not the case for
the blue lines which are the actions
when we play against this adversarial
agent in which case the blue victims
actions are not normal in the slightest
so the adversarial agent is really doing
nothing but it is doing nothing in a way
that reprograms its opponent to make
mistakes and behave close to a
completely randomly acting agent this
paper is absolute insanity I love it and
if you look here you see that the more
the blue curve improves the better this
scheme works for a given game for
instance it is doing real good on kick
and defend fairly good on sumo humans
that there is something about the sumo
ants game that prevents this interesting
kind of hypnosis from happening I love
to see a follow-up paper that can pull
this off a little more reliably what a
time to be alive what you see here is an
instrumentation of this exact paper we
have talked about which was made by
weights and biases
I think organizing these experiments
really showcases the usability of their
system weights and biases provides tools
to track your experiments in your deep
learning projects their system is
designed to save you a ton of time and
money and it is actively used in
projects at prestigious labs such as
open AI Toyota research github and more
and the best part is that if you are an
academic or have an open-source project
you can use their tools for free it
really is as good as it gets
make sure to visit them through wnb comm
slash papers or just click the link in
the video description and you can get a
free demo today
our thanks to weights and biases for
their long-standing support and for
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time